our hands and we say we will be free
desmond tutu was the country's moral
conscience when most anti-apartheid
leaders in south africa had been
silenced and imprisoned
a leader of the congregation who also
led the protest march he was never
afraid to step in or chide the
authorities
the reason he was as mandela said
public enemy number one to white south
africans was that he got under their
skin because he
he he spoke out he used to say he used
to quote the book of jeremiah in the old
testament and say
and say like jeremiah the prophet i have
to speak out i'm actually a retiring
kind of a person and
but i have to speak out and it's the
anger which drove him
[Music]
during some of south africa's most
turbulent years tutu made the case for
comprehensive reform and his efforts won
him the nobel peace prize in 1984
and it was he who held up nelson
mandela's arm as the first
democratically elected president in
1994. this is the day
for which we have waited for over 300
years
[Applause]
this is the day
of liberation
mandela promised to investigate the
crimes of the apartheid era and desmond
tutu was the obvious choice to lead the
process through a truth and
reconciliation commission
but it wasn't easy
and the archbishop very publicly broke
down
midway through the commission he was
diagnosed with prostate cancer but it
didn't slow him down
the man known as south africa's naughty
uncle continued to laugh and engage
and criticized as well his democratic
rights used to castigate domestic
politicians here condemning a decision
by the ruling anc to refuse the dalai
lama a visa
our country
is worse than
the abadi government
by the time of nelson mandela's death
archbishop tutu had fallen out with the
authorities
his family said he wasn't invited to
mandela's funeral a charge which led to
a hasty last minute invitation
the government of then president jacob
zuma said it was a misunderstanding
a few months later tutu said he wouldn't
vote for the ruling anc a decision his
daughter also backed
he is disappointed
with um
with the
assaults on our democracy with the
levels of corruption with the amounts of
graft with the
wanton wastefulness
he made one of his last public
appearances in cape town when he met
archie son of the duke and duchess of
sussex
his infectious sense of fun was on full
display
[Applause]
he will be remembered for his energy and
decency his authenticity
a south african icon who was loved and
appreciated far beyond his homeland
john sparks sky news in johannesburg